يعني انت يعني
فنان غادرت
غادرت سوريا الوطن المكان الاول مطارح
الاولى حمص
والميادين حلب ودمشق بدون شك يعني هذا
خزان كبير خزان كبير يعني واسئله حملتها
معك وتحملنا دائما ماذا يعني لك ان تجد
حمص على غير حمص التي كانت وحلب على غيرك
على غير شكل دمرت
يعني شيء مؤسف لهذا الشيء امانه على صعيد
النفسي والانساني وعلى الصعيد الشخصي
بالنسبه الي اماكن انتمي اليها واماكن
يعني هي ذاكرتي وليس جزء من ذاكرتي ذاكره
الاولى واللبنه الاولى لافكار
والاجتراحات الفنيه كلها ابتدات من نهر
الفرات ومن ومن حمص وايضا دمشق كما قلت
انا يبدو قدري اسكن الى جانب الانهار من
نهر الفرات نهر العاصي الى نهر الفرات
وبعد ذلك نهر برد تخيل نهر برد بدمشق كان
يجري في بيته يعني كان عندي بيت اكبر من
هذا القصر
في دمشق في منطقه الربا يعني كان بيت كبير
جدا من العهد العثماني للاهل لا لي شخصيا
يعني لكن يعني انت رجل ثري الثري بلغتي
بفمي وعلى المستوى العملي انا المستوى
العملي اموري ليست سيئه لكن يعني احاول ان
اعوض عن الفقد المادي لهذه الاشياء او
لتاريخي بالانتصار الفني يعني عملت من
سنتين معرض
بفرنسا باونجي معرض ضخم 70 عمل كان هو بين
الفرات
نهر الفرات اللي هو في الميادين نهر الجنه
نهر التاريخ ونهر للوار اللي هو نهر
الحاضر فكان بين نهرين وهو كون الحضارات
على طول هي
تنمو على شواطئ البحار حتى الاسطوره تقول
ان نوح عندما نزل بعد الطوفان كتب
الابجديات كامله على الالواح هو الطوفان
ساهم بانتشارها عن طريق الانهار حلوه
هالخيال الجميل يعني اقبل فيه كا اسطوره
كخيال لانه تعرف الخيال يغذي ويعطي تاويل
اخر
للمعاش او للواقع